hi Thomas AQ hard Mountain Dew to be
your companion in times of bounty or in
times of need to have and to hold from
this day forward for better well it may
not be equal love but there certainly is
some love here happily ever after for
this Indiana man Thomas rank is his name
he became manned and can after he
married a hard Mountain Dew can at the
little Vegas Chapel yesterday all part
of a fan contest with hard Mountain Dew
for single folks who want to show off
their unwavering love and Devotion to
Mountain Dew
I can say I'm the first person to ever
marry a can of hard Mountain Dew a Canon
General and it's been a big step not
only for myself but all of mankind as
well Mom I'm married a can I know that's
not what you're expecting and you
thought my older brother get married
first but here I am and you know what I
can't be happier so love has no labels
race to the altar apparently between the
brothers rank also spent a couple nights
in a Vegas Suite got a thousand bucks
and spending money and he got a custom
ring with a soda tab on it there it is
all kinds of fancy